bonsoir nous avons beaucoup de chance
d'être devant vous ce soir déjà parce
que vous êtes resté donc ça c'est déjà
pas mal
et puis ben parce que moi je suis une
femme
moi aussi je pense mauvezin on a de la
chance je suis vieille je me suis jamais
c'est un avantage ça veut dire je suis
toujours vivante
donc c'est déjà pas mal on a aussi
beaucoup de chance parce qu'on vit en
france et on a une grande liberté
notamment d'expression
on a aussi de la chance et moi
particulièrement mais ça viendra pour
toi puisque je suis universitaire je
suis enseignant chercheur depuis 25 ans
à l'université et moi ça fait 2 5 années
donc si j'enlève la virgule ça fait
presque mon âge ce qui presque est donc
en fait à nos deux on a pas mal
d'expérience des expériences différentes
des bonnes expériences d'autres bonnes
aussi en fait mais différente et je t'en
prie et depuis un an et demi avec
d'autres universitaires nous avons
constitué un groupe de recherche qui
s'appelle i des moeurs et donc il porte
sur un objet qui nous passionne la mer
enfin presque
nous allons y revenir alors je sais pas
si vous le savez mais quand on est
enseignant à l'université on est surtout
chercheurs monde et principalement
chercheurs c'est là dessus qu'on est con
et notés et donc on appartient des
équipes de recherche qu'on appelle des
laboratoires qui sont eux-mêmes donc
dépendante d'université ou de
fédérations d'université me demandez pas
à quoi ça sert je sais pas qui dépendent
aussi ou pas du cnrs qui sont rattachés
à des fédérations de groupes de
recherche qui sont eux mêmes parfois
labellisés ou pas qui font tout ce
qu'ils peuvent pour trouver des sous et
donc pour décrocher des projets à nerfs
me demandez pas ce que veut dire je ne
sais pas et puis on dépend aussi on est
contrôlé en fait part des agences qui
nous contrôle alors retenez pas les noms
parce que façon ça change tout le temps
et comme on vient de changer de
gouvernement ça va encore changer
donc c'est pas grave donc en fait eh
bien on a parfois plus l'impression
quand on est chercheur de passer notre
temps à ramer ramer pour trouver des
sous à ramer pour faire des dossiers
pour prouver qu on fait de la recherche
plutôt que d'en faire comme si en fait
on passait notre temps à la plage mais
on fait aussi de la recherche à la plage
ça pour ça autour de la plage par
exemple
ivan en tant que géographe à travailler
il y a près de 30 ans sur l'île d'yeu où
elle a notamment cartographier les zones
de pêche
pour ma part en tant que cattenoz log et
bien je travaille aussi sur l'île d'yeu
où je documente et je collecte des
savoirs relatifs aux savoirs péché
qu'ils soient traditionnels ou
contemporains et ensemble eh bien nous
croisons nos données nous mobilisons nos
savoirs de manière à identifier et à
comprendre les processus de transmission
et d'adaptation du monde de la pêche
voilà et pourtant même si les
institutions c'est complexe au niveau de
la recherche et bien nous on a toujours
envie de faire de nouveaux trucs on a
toujours envie de porter de nouveaux
projets et donc en l'occurrence eh bien
on va vous présenter aujourd'hui notre
projet donc qui est un projet de
recherche sur la mer alors là vous allez
me dire c'est bon les filles quoi la mer
les océanographes s'en occupe il ya les
océanographes ya les bio logiciel est
physicien et à les chimistes tout le
monde s'occupe de la mer qu'est ce que
vous allez ramener votre fraises vous
sur la mer donc ils ont tous vu les
courants les vagues les petites bêtes
qui sont dans celles qui sont dessus
même les micro plastiques a priori
m'enfin bon et donc non c'est dit ben
oui mais bon vous avez écouté la musique
tout de suite ce chanteur du millénaire
dernier
art mengo lui dit la mer n'existe pas
que la mer est une illusion
et si la mère n'existait pas et si ce
n'était pas une réalité mais plutôt une
idée
eh bien nous en fait c'est un peu ce qui
va nous nous motiver moi je suis
géographe et quand j'étais en première
année j'avais un prof de géo qui disait
un paysage
ça existe quand on le regarde si
personne ne le regarde le paysage
n'existe pas puisque vous neame n'est
pas votre identité vous neame n'est pas
votre histoire vous n'y allez pas votre
affects et puis de façon si personne ne
regarde y'a pas de paysages et
finalement la mer ça peut être un petit
peu pareil l'anr
la mer est peuplé d'animaux d'êtres
vivants de monstres marins
elle est aussi occupée par les sommes
qu'ils explorent voir l'exploitent de
long en large et en profondeur et donc
en fait alors que aujourd'hui
pratiquement tous les grands acteurs du
monde de l'europe de la france commence
à parler de stratégie maritime
on s'est attaqué à la terre il ya plus
rien sur la terre on va s'attaquer à la
mer donc de stratégie maritime
nous on veut avoir un regain regard un
peu différent sur cet objet on veut
prendre un peu de recul par rapport à
cet objet pour décortiquer avec les
sciences que nous portons donc les
sciences les sciences humaines
ce qu'on écrit ce qu'on dit de la mer
comment on apprivoise la mer comment on
s'approprie la mer et ce sur divers
territoires
parce que ce que nous apprennent les
sciences sociales
c'est qu'en regardant ailleurs à l'autre
bout du monde ou chez son propre voisin
on en apprend sur lui mais aussi sur
nous nos pratiques nos représentations
nos propres représentations et il s'agit
bien de prendre de la distance par
rapport à un objet qui nous semble être
naturel et qui pourtant est bien souvent
un construit culturel par exemple la
crise des océans dont on nous parle tant
est ce un phénomène propre au 21ème
siècle
et qu'en est il de ces designers et de
ces artistes qui créent aujourd'hui avec
du plastique recyclé sont ils si
différents de nos ancêtres les pinces
ailleurs à ce propos nos télés date du
23 24 et 25 novembre prochain puisque
nous avons convié des chercheurs du
monde entier à venir discuter de ce que
c'est que la mer et il y aura également
des artistes qui vont proposer une
exploration multisensorielle ici au pôle
ségalen de ce que c'est que la mer et de
ski la façade
donc en fait si on s'interroge sur ce
que c'est que la mer on va s'interroger
sur la place donc de la mer et des
océans dans notre dans notre conscient
on va dire dans notre dans nos
représentations
alors la mer d'abord elle est tout
puissant
elle est chargée de sacrés les charges
et de mythologie d'histoire d'histoire
collective l'histoire individuelle
la mère elle est aussi pour jouer
pourvoyeuse de richesse de richesses
halieutiques énormément de poissons de
richesses énergétiques aussi et puis de
plus en plus on l'a vu sur les
présentations précédentes de richesse de
déchets qui sont aussi en quantité
phénoménale
la mer c'est bien sûr aussi une source
de plaisir je vous ai mis mon dernier
château de sable là donc voilà donc on a
tous à un moment a été on a tous un
petit peu dans notre tête ses châteaux
de sable qu'on a pu faire
la mer c'est aussi une source de plaisir
de loisirs de davanture de records à on
a vu aussi avec les surfeurs la défense
d'y emmener nous donc et est donc la mer
s'est aussi hissé aussi cela avec
énormément de récits de récits parfois
par procuration un an qu'on peut avoir
et la mer c'est aussi quelque chose de
très menaçant la mer ça peut être
dangereux
la mère s'est pollué oui mais ce qui est
polluée pour certains ne l'est pas pour
d'autres
par exemple les micro billes en
plastique que l'on peut collecter dans
le sable citons tels que l'on utilise un
tamis ou encore les filets de pêche
qu'ils soient énormes ou coupés peuvent
être de prison plus récupérer pour être
recyclés voilà on va le perturber
en tout cas nous avec qui des verts on
s'intéresse aux paradoxes
par exemple le paradoxe de la plage que
l'on voudrait être un espace vierge
vierge de tout savez-vous qu aujourd'hui
il ya des enfants et des adultes qui
considère que les algues sont quelque
chose de sale qui n'ont pas leur place
sur la plage est donc aujourd'hui des
enfants comme des adultes et bien mettre
ces algues dans des sacs poubelle
lorsqu'il participe à des nettoyages de
plages adieu donc en fait il n'y aurait
pas d' idées universelles de la mer on
est ici sur une approche donc avec des
hypothèses et des affaires
qui sont très différents on a pris un
exemple ici donc d'une première enquête
qu'on a fait faut que je reste
on a pris donc une première enquête
qu'on a fait donc en 2016 en irlande et
en france donc sur l'imaginaire en fait
d'aider des habitants donc de des
irlandais et des francs et des français
et donc on leur a demandé à quoi
pensez-vous spontanément quand on évoque
la mer et les océans et or ce qui est
assez drôle c'est que pour les deux
peuples
la mer et les océans ce qui leur vient
en premier c'est moby dick
et c'est le vieil homme et la mer c'est
assez drôle quand même parce que moby
dick est le vieil homme et la mer c'est
red hat et kom kom kom ouvrage alors à
priori ça doit être étudiée donc dans le
lycée et dans les écoles des deux côtés
après on va retrouver des films des
séries des fictions mais là où on a une
différence au niveau de l'irlande et de
la france c'est qu'ensuite on va
retrouver pour les irlandais la mer à
travers les légendes et les chants et
pour les français la mer à travers ce
qu'on appelle les livres de pêche qui
traitent des preuves de pêche
donc on est ici un sur une approche qui
est complètement différente et qui est
différent selon les territoires
ce qui va nous amener à travailler avec
d'autres collègues dans d'autres
universités et donc on va se poser la
question de ckoi la mer c'est quoi la
mère en france
c'est quoi la mer en irlande c'est quoi
la mer en islande
c'est quoi la mer en écosse en finlande
et en australie
et donc nous mobilisons les expertises
et les méthodes de travail d'historien
de géographes des dialogues mais aussi
de littéraires de civilisation nist ou
encore d'économistes ou encore même de
psychologues et donc interroger la
construction des représentations de la
mer des valeurs qui sont associés et des
pratiques s'est aussi essayé
d'identifier les comportements sociaux
d'identifier les modes de consommation
qui sont liées aussi à ces comportements
c'est essayer de faciliter la prise de
conscience de la fragilité du mythe du
milieu marin du milieu littoral et de la
fragilité aussi des sociétés qui y
vivent
et donc en fait cela peut aider à porter
des réglementations à mettre en place
des réglementations sur la protection de
l'environnement une loi pour qu'elle
soit appliquée il suffit pas de la
promulguer il faut aussi la porte et ça
peut aider aussi à changer les modes de
consommation pour venir sur des
consommation plus responsable plus
raisonnable aussi des espèces fragiles
et aussi des espaces qui sont
particulièrement fragiles et donc nous
accompagnons aussi des institutions ou
des partenaires privés par exemple
actuellement nous documentons des
savoirs relatifs au monde de la pêche de
manière à les transmettre à une
association qui s'est donnée comme
objectif de créer un nouvel outil de
travail un catamaran un catamaran pour
de la pêche durable et responsable
donc pour ce faire nous menons des
entretiens avec des marins en activité
nous sollicitons de vieux armateurs et
avec des étudiants nous montons une
exposition itinérante de manière
valoriser ces données mais aussi à les
transmettre auprès des jeunes marins en
formation est donc en fait notre nouveau
groupe de recherche donc ils s'appellent
idée maire a toute sa place dans la
recherche contemporaine
en fait on veut continuer à analyser à
déconstruire les discours les discours
politiques
les discours économique les discours
culturel qui sont portés sur la mère à
travers des termes comme la croissance
bleue des termes comme la montée des
océans
la stratégie maritime la disparition des
espèces
la maritimité qu'est ce qu'il se cache
derrière ces termes quand on les emploie
quand un politique les emplois ou quand
quentin économistes les emplois et donc
nous ce qu'on veut c'est montrer les
liens les tensions les synergies qui
existent entre les discours les valeurs
et les pratiques
donc pour conclure idée mars est un
projet de recherche qui est
pluridisciplinaire et transversale et
pour cela ben le plan disciplinaire
c'est pas facile je pense que les gens
du fal bla peuvent le dire parce qu'il
faut s'ouvrir à l'autre
il faut comprendre comment l'autre
fonctionne il
faut comprendre son vocabulaire le même
mot ne veut pas dire la même chose il
faut comprendre ses méthodes il faut
donc aussi comprendre et accepter son
expertise et pour cela est bien bien
souvent il faut savoir faire un pas de
côté et c'est donc pour cela que nous
sommes deux ce soir devant vous pour
rendre compte de cette dynamique
relationnelle le fait que tous les jours
on en apprend on apprend de nouvelles
idées de nouveaux concepts de nouvelles
formulations tout simplement
et finalement nous avons décidé de
dédier cette présentation
bien sûr avoue qu'être là ce soir mais
aussi à toutes les personnes que l'on
rend compte au fil de nos recherches des
experts reconnus ou des personnes
anonymes
et puis à tous les étudiants et aussi
aux futurs chercheurs
je vous remercie nous vous remercions
[Applaudissements]